tuckahoe new york a wealthy old commuter
town 45 minutes north of manhattan and
home to the old stone mill restaurant
and bar but now the old stone mill is in
danger of grinding to a halt for good
okay six years ago i took this place
and i began my quest to convert this old
mill into a restaurant and
here we are open four years now
done we took a risk there's no investors
here
you know we built it out i did
everything in here myself is this the
right spot
all the woodwork the carpentry the
plumbing
the only thing i really didn't get
involved in was the electrical work
[Music]
okay i don't believe there's a better
operator or restaurateur than me
but no one's coming in
or trying to come in i'm embarrassed
that i can't go out with the sides that
i need for a table my boss dean he's a
panty he has come in and screamed at me
come on man read the [ __ ] tickets
it's horrible
it's absolutely horrible what the [ __ ]
do i still have passion for food
no
and it shows
there were days i just couldn't think of
eating the food
i eat my food and my family eats my food
and i think it's good
we don't have a very young crowd there
is a assisted living facility right
behind us and we do have a lot of the
blue heads come in
that's that's that's the customer base
hopefully the entrees will come soon
service please we do have a problem with
the service because it is very hard to
get people to work here can i get
someone here to clean the sink i'm
missing a dish here missing a knife a
little piece of glass on the table never
heard anyone right
i have a reoccurring nightmare that i've
had from day one
what happens if i open up staffed up
food ready and
no one decides to come here
well it happened
this year i don't know i don't have
answers for that i wish i did
when you're making no money it's
very hard to convince you that tomorrow
is going to be a better day when you
have bills to pay
it's not that nice when it's slow well
the slow night there's a lot of sad
faces you tell me what to do
well what to do
let everybody earn money and let dean
take it in the ass as always why aren't
more people coming here
i don't know
i really really don't know
being behind on my mortgage and
the thought of them foreclosing on my
house i just couldn't i couldn't take it
i can't take it
hi honey hi babe i need money for dry
cleaning
money
what about these people i think they
need money
i think my wife might know these last
couple of months have been the worst
ever for me i'm going to be up here and
see who the lucky people are they're
going to get paid today
this restaurant isn't just a restaurant
it's our life it's our future it's our
children's future
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful
thank you
bye
[Music]
you all ready to go and himself should
be here any minute i almost drove by
this place
what a beautiful building what scares me
is why no one's eating here i'm about to
find out
[Music]
gordon
how are you i'm dean
nice to see you very nice to see you
good to see you too thanks for coming by
no matter what you say the guy's a
winner his michelin stars are like world
series rings he's got them
tom tell them how i went
this is the the barman yes this is the
chief cook and bottle washer here okay
fantastic you know i know his
credentials i know how good he is i'm
starving oh okay i do believe gordon
could help the restaurant
but
how much so i don't know genie this is
gordon ramsay when he approached me and
put out his hand said hello to me well
first of all i like blonde men so he was
adorable gene nice to see you i felt a
very warm feeling so glamorous gordon
will be a plus in my life
this is our menu it says a little
history on one side and a menu on the
other thank you you got it
[Music]
so i'd like to know the cupcakes i've
made with fresh crab meat fresh lovely
i'll start off with crab cake i'd like
to see a shrimp please i'll have the
chopped salad please thank you and then
for um main course risotto and then i'll
go for the tilapia on papillon
michael
you do things your way i am very nervous
he's going to come in here i'm going to
cook for him and he's going to say yeah
are you um chewing gum
yes sir you are is that normal
i suppose
ready
apart from being slow the waiters think
it's normal to chew gum
hey
come on let's go
send it out can you have somebody of his
caliber come in i don't know what he's
gonna do i don't know what he's gonna
say
cool
thank you
[Music]
it tastes really strange
i can't put my finger on it
something really weird in there it's
like a sour mayonnaise flavor
i'm hoping that he likes one of the
dishes that he ordered two of the dishes
maybe all of the dishes
[Music]
wrapped in feel of pace deep fat fried
i've eaten some prawns in my life but
[ __ ] me that's the first
i'll have to help
make it out gordon
is this a popular dish on the menu
yes
wow
so far i don't think he's like this
[Music]
what is that a chap salad oh chop salad
so excuse me look at that what's that
squashed into looks like it's been
squashing it's an ice cream cone
okay that's it there
right that sits on top was the chef a
mechanic
no no aside from its appearance that
people actually
enjoy it
you know this is my house he was in my
house and he was
embarrassing me
[Music]
okay
[Music]
please don't make me anymore this [ __ ]
take this out while this is still puffy
please
lovely thank you
looks like someone's out of [ __ ] in the
bag and stuck it in the oven
oh dear
disappointment was written all over his
face
he doesn't like any of the food
so far it's gross
pretty gross basically told me
everything was serving his [ __ ]
what'd you expect them to say everything
was great every single dish he had
sucked you know i i can't help but get
defensive
risotto
the chef likes all this little mashed
lamb lettuce
sadly it's hot and disgusting the rice
just
purees in your mouth it like sort of
sticks to the roof of your mouth
well a russian can't even cook a simple
mushroom risotto
it's a big worry
gordon didn't like the food
it didn't seem to like anything so
nobody's feeling too good right now
if you're gonna be a restaurant at least
know what your food tastes like i don't
think this guy's got a [ __ ] clue what
his food tastes like
okay
take a seat sit down right um that was
interesting um interesting but
bitterly disappointing is that canned
crab that's not fresh crab meat is it
it's can't grab
when i asked very politely is the crab
meat fresh the waiter told me yes of
course it is the waiter told you that
was fresh crabmeat yeah that's why i
ordered it first one arrived stone cold
i'm sorry
let's have a little taste there
and eat that for me
look at it it looked like it came out of
a baby's diaper huh
no one's gonna come back for that
that as a chopped salad i mean it's
hideous let's have a taste of that
my eight-year-old daughter could cook
better than that
probably from anyone else i would have
threw the table over and threw them out
honestly
your food's crap
[Music]
he's a little harsh
and he got to be a little abusive on the
food
oh [ __ ]
what the hell did we get into if you
think that you're gonna continue
running this business serving that [ __ ]
you might as well turn this place into a
museum no one's going to come back for
this
i was pissed
real pissed i wanted to take the plate
and smash it on top of the chef's head
[Music]
in order to fully understand all the
issues of the old stone mill it's time
to get tight-lipped dean to open up
and these questions may not be
comfortable dean but unless i understand
the full scenario then i can't get this
place back online
one thing i'd like to know is the
financial
situation
are you aware of the current financial
situation brother
um he kind of keeps me in the dark a
little bit i don't want her to worry
no reason for her to share these anxiety
and nerves that i have
totally unnecessary
i try not to bring it up
[Music]
it's always easier just to kind of not
think about what's going on here and
that's probably one of the reasons why i
don't
come down very often to the restaurant
because
what you don't know can't hurt you i
just choose not to deal with it right
now i'll let him deal with it if the
house gets taken away you lose that then
every reason to be worried
i mean the bottom line is you're losing
money correct every week every week yes
if we
had to close yeah tonight
just switch everything off yeah we
owe
half a million
half a million yeah
it wouldn't be good for our marriage i
don't think if he would risk you know
everything that we possibly had in the
world
got money tied up in the
home
mortgage-wise oh sure
a mortgage a second mortgage on a home
equity line got so that's backed up big
time yeah
how do you manage in terms of getting
through month to month in terms of
mortgage payments
suppliers salaries
your salary what do you want me to say
it's it's you know i'm in hell right now
[Music]
please don't get upset i know no no no
it's crucial for me to understand
exactly where we are no i know i've got
to be really frank and honest
that's why you're here
[Music]
nothing is more telling to gordon than
observing a full dinner service
fortunately it's saturday night the one
night the restaurant is busy hi how are
you all right well enjoy your dinner hi
folks how are you i know you'll be happy
with that and
can't go wrong
tonight i am on the edge cause now the
fear of failure's setting in the cashew
chicken primary medium ram
as orders begin to arrive in the kitchen
fried calamari chopped salad crab cakes
one prime rib medium rare two cashew
chicken chef michael is clearly
frustrated you see anybody run a line by
themselves uh not like this before no
you know it's just me and you have to
get it done you get it done it's not
easy when you're by yourself it really
isn't i'm not saying it is easy
michael works more than is expected of a
normal chef he does above and beyond
as chef michael continues to fight the
battles alone in the kitchen
nice to meet you owner dean and manager
tom are in their own world in the front
of the house another day paradise huh hi
how are you
perfect i think i might have a beer with
you oh really cheers
say the truth
there is no place like this in
pennsylvania there's no place like home
as the manager here i do whatever it
takes to keep the place running as
smoothly as possible
and where's your strengths are you
strengthening what
[Music]
[Laughter]
an hour into dinner service and the
overly embellished dishes finally emerge
from the kitchen
mike tries to presentate the food
real nice what's this crack here with
calamari in the martini glass we're just
trying different presentations because
the
the dishes we have
suck i can't believe you'd be so [ __ ]
polite
holy mackerel
[Music]
i don't even know what to tell you
and neither gordon
or the customers
there's too are impressed
okay
is it cold
is there enough sauce on these cashew
chickens yes there is i'm football
when it just becomes a job not that you
don't care not that you don't put in the
effort but it's just the same [ __ ] every
day by the way the the the paper's
edible
i've never had my dinner served to me
i don't know why the fries are looking
remarkably shitty tonight in your
business right now yeah i wish that was
the only problem a [ __ ] french fry
is it cold
send it back send it back y'all excuse
me you were there okay
just okay
just okay just okay with food now being
sent back to the kitchen already behind
michael is now totally overwhelmed i
need a result going to tilapia and
that's done and dean is not helping the
problems but adding to them
i got backed up because it was too much
at once oh my god over come on come on
get this to get this to 28 boober right
now mikey that's a risotto
it's overcooked god damn it
got me very frustrated let the customer
wait if he waits 20 minutes and he's
happy or he waits 20 minutes gets crap
what's worse let him wait 20 minutes and
be happy give me that ditch man please
send it out right now michael yes sir
are you happy with that risotto not
really jeff no
michael if you're not happy with it
why'd you serve it my man
chef to chef now why not forget forget
dean where's the
yeah dean he's the owner ultimately it's
his decision hi
yeah
right now i just want to get people
their food
what's the matter with
this it's very salty mushrooms
it make you feel better if we rushed him
to the table
no
i'm trying to ask the chef about some
form of standard and you're just like
get the [ __ ] [ __ ] out because the
lady asked me three times for food i'm
amazed you know that more than anything
i don't know i don't know what you i
don't know what you want me to say to
you your restaurant is on the ass
that's what um but it's done it's sun
gordon it's done
i love the facade you put across it you
know it's not a facade yes it is no it's
not yeah actually we were just going to
ask you about the risotto
i think it's really salty i don't really
like
it
[Music]
what they said
dean's willingness to send out
substandard risotto typifies what's
wrong with the old stone mill
in addition a great deal of dean's
energy has gone into beautifying the
restaurant
but the menu has been neglected
i don't think you understand the real
reason why i'm here the inconsistencies
of food is obvious
the food needs some serious attention
and yet no one seems to address it i
asked michael
are you happy with the risotto
he said no
and you said no i've got to serve i've
got to serve it i'll be waiting 50
minutes have you any idea how much
damage you're causing what do you want
what what it's not about what i want
it's just what i'm
i'm miffed i'm not too sure if you're
actually
hungry for the change you know that
it's one thing to believe in a dream but
it's another thing to actually be in a
dream world
for every plate of food we send
we're narrowing the chances of this
place becoming successful
and i think you bully them into making
sure that
they get brainwashed
to how you think
well let me tell you something
what you think is wrong
it's tough to get poked out all day i
feel like poking back right now
i'm trying to get through to you
so i can't get through to you i've got
no chance
i think you're treating us like a game
how dare you accuse me of not having a
commitment hey you i don't know i'm
telling you you're not telling me
anything this is your own figment of
your imagination that i don't have a
commitment to this place dean's a
fighter he's not gonna back down from a
challenge
you just give me two minutes you guys
would you mind
you float on the customers coming round
blowing smoke up your ass that's right i
do when i ask people how their food is
they tell me it's good it makes me feel
good i don't wobble around my customers
kissing how was it please tell me don't
go to the table yes people had a meal
was or no you probably paid ten people
to go to the table i listen to the phone
every morning see how [ __ ] fully
booked i have this is what i get i need
to do to stand in here that's what i get
paid to do to sit here next to people
and give them a good [ __ ] experience
that's when i get paid watch this [ __ ]
come out no
that doesn't feel good about it no i
don't feel good there you go again
that's my opinion about it you [ __ ]
did that's what i got to do that's what
i do you're a fake [ __ ] you you're a
fake
you're a [ __ ] fate
is how you're gonna act walk away can
you not face it like a [ __ ] man
[Applause]
it's what i gotta do that's what i do
you're a fake [ __ ] you you're a fake
you're a [ __ ] face
you're full of [ __ ] is that how you're
gonna act walk away cannot face it like
a [ __ ] man i face everything like a
man i don't stay away from nothing
that's right nothing
nothing not you
nothing
i have a commitment to this place that
you'll probably never have any place in
your life ever what
did i stutter i just told you how i feel
about this place i'm not gonna suck your
dick to make you believe me if you don't
believe me you don't believe me you
don't like the truth dean no i do like
the truth no one's birth your [ __ ]
mother i heard the truth of my life more
than you'll ever hear the truth [ __ ]
yeah that's what you think you take
pride in your hair your trousers shirt
you're well groomed i just want you to
take pride in what the [ __ ] you do in a
business and if you applied what you
applied in yourself each and every day
you won't be serving that shed
right now we've got some issues in here
and unless you're prepared to change
this place has got no chance
and you've had it all your own [ __ ]
way for such a long time
and it's not going to continue being
like that
one thing has to change instantly
you
[Music]
ironically it's dean's fear of failure
that is preventing him from making the
necessary changes for success
but before gordon can put his plan for
change into action he decides to explore
the local competition italian
chinese restaurant
next door to pizzeria
an american bistro
how weird another italian restaurants
everywhere
another italian to my yard
[Music]
how are you very good good to see you
too and what a beautiful little shop
thank you very much busy little place
very busy fantastic for the great meat
eaters here yes they are they love their
steaks and they like them thick been up
and down the street there's not one
steakhouse anywhere no there isn't does
no one ever open one here ah i don't
know but if it was a steakhouse local
you could supply it
it would be a pleasant change well
listen thank you okay good to see you
have a good weekend okay thank you paul
chef thank you again take care okay
nice
now armed with local knowledge gordon
knows that to turn this restaurant
around he must get the chef back on
track michael this restaurant needs to
be known for something
first big change
prime ribs rib on the bone okay this is
a special to get this place in the right
direction to make your life easier to
make service
quicker i am very nervous it's not every
day that you get to cook with a
world-class chef you know how to slice
it from that on you down and all up yeah
exactly
go ahead and put that beef in here i'm
excited to learn those new dishes
and then after time just put my own spin
on him and hope he doesn't come back and
throw me under the bus the idea behind
the chopped salad is having that little
bit of crunch there yeah
romaine
shredded a few chinese a little bit of
bacon in there half dress so it stays
nice and crunchy little seasoning on the
avocado your tomato chopped egg if your
chives
meltdown okay
yes
oh just think of the complaints what
you're not stuffing my salad in a funnel
what do you mean you're not serving me a
funnel salad mike you're all right with
this i'm fine with that i left my ass
off when he burned those funnels with
the creme brulee torture i left and i
understood his point there's nothing
wrong with a simple salad don't try and
make it anything that it's not if they
come and ask me for their salad to be
stuck inside a funnel i will personally
lift them and put them next door in the
retirement home
okay
last of the [ __ ] funnel
[Music]
with the chef re-energized gordon turns
his attention to the owner and his team
dean has always had the desire to
succeed now chef ramsay is about to tell
him how to do it okay i've done my
homework
i've been out and about and i [ __ ] i
i've studied hard what isn't in the town
[Music]
there's not one good steakhouse anywhere
in this town
this place has got every chance of
becoming a phenomenal steakhouse
chef gordon's idea of a steakhouse would
really work here he's 100 right that
there is nothing else in the area give
the locals what they want and get them
coming
time and time again and make money
i'm listening to gordon i'm listening to
everything he said and he's making all
these changes but when the changes are
done i don't know if he's going to get
people through the door this place oozes
steakhouse
i cannot tell you
look forward to it
how did you sit
[Music]
i can't afford to make many changes
because i can't afford to alienate or
lose what i have right now
i'm fuming they give me a little bit of
manhood
i'm not insane i had a vision
you cooked a simple prime rib
that was your resurrection of the place
was a simple prime rib hey i'm sorry
i've got 12 successful russians highly
profitable and you my man missed out on
a [ __ ] trick when you change concepts
when you change
direction so radically i think that's a
sign of weakness
tomorrow we're changing the menu we're
going to re-launch the restaurant you've
got some serious thinking to do
good night
[Music]
it's day four relaunch day and time for
dean to embrace the changes that will
hopefully save his restaurant gordon
secretly has brought in his design team
who worked through the night to spruce
up the old stone mill you know when i
first arrived here yeah i drove by this
beautiful building without actually
realizing it was a restaurant
no sign no nothing let's have a look yes
one
two three up
look at it beautiful the natural stone
the old stone mill steakhouse
now we know what the place is when we
drive by
when they unveiled the sign it was just
absolutely beautiful i was breathtaking
deans like it i love it ah it's great
very nice look next to it steakhouse
why didn't i do it call the sign guy
work out a barter with him do a trade do
something and get the sign i could have
i don't know why right let's go inside
there's more history
this is all the stuff that's been
upstairs that you've been kept away so
when customers aren't waiting you know
they can get an insight to what you've
done i want people to know from the
first minute they walk in here that your
heart is in here i was a little
intimidated when i first walked in
because i didn't know what to expect
every nook every bloody piece of stone
look the history's there
gordon putting up these pictures of me
building the place blew me away okay
there's more come through beautiful
absolutely beautiful oh my god
wow now everybody can see everybody
oh it's lovely it's just beautiful i
can't even put it into words
it's open it's classic we've got new
plates new linen new tableware barbara
what do you think
rid of the dark colors too depressing
yes too depressing the candles on all
the tables the fresh flowers it's just
bright it's cheery it's a place you want
to be i'm speechless
i'm speechless
the same restaurant the same people but
something is different
we have gordon ramsay's touch smell
let's see if it works it has to work
it's there now there's no [ __ ] excuse
we've got rid of the clutter look at it
looks great ah looks great i didn't know
what to expect i didn't know any of this
involved any kind of a makeover of any
sort but um i'm man enough to admit that
it's great
even though the improvements to the
decor are well received that was an easy
change to accept now for the hard one
the new steakhouse menu okay let's uh
let's go through the food very very
quickly yes menu let's start off with
the uh meats that's the porterhouse
steak for two you've got the most
amazing ribeye next to that you've got
the new york strip the most popular
steak across america
i expected the blend of the old and new
but changing the menu completely
surprised me the most
halibut has a really nice sort of rustic
meaty flavor you know it's a very robust
fish but pan said is beautiful and then
the crispy skin salmon spaghetti a
squash coffee shallot and a really nice
crispy skin yes okay the appetizers um
steam mussels nice big bowl and then the
cream corn every steakhouse across the
states has got creamed corn on there and
then my favorite the old stone meal
chopped salad sadly no funnel
[Music]
it's gonna be a challenge but uh it's
very exciting to have a new monument
with two hours to go before the doors
open gordon wants to make sure the
restaurant feels like the steakhouse in
town and before anyone eats any food it
will be up to the front of the house
staff this is now a steakhouse we're
going to confirm it each and every table
arrives this evening a quick
presentation bingo tom sell it to me
[Music]
my worries are that the food's changed
the aesthetics have changed but i still
have my dysfunctional staff
hello
welcome to the old snowmelt steakhouse
here are the steaks we have this evening
this is our
our 21 day
aged
[ __ ] day let's go we have a
i'm completely out of my comfort zone
you can't expect to win the gold medal
in a week
and on the top a kobe
strip
come on a kobe strip sounds like a
[ __ ] japanese lap dancing car
it's still the same mediocre crew in
there god almighty
gordon has introduced a lot of changes
to the old stone mill in just a few days
and with their heads still reeling it's
time for dean and his staff to rise to
the occasion hello how are you we're
excited about tonight we're hoping this
goes over well for us
[Music]
what do you think about the new look i
love it it's a new start i'm exhausted
i'm emaciated i'm tired i'm anxious
tonight yeah i'm sure hope so i was a
little nervous going into it not knowing
a menu at all only seeing it maybe at
two hours before we were supposed to
start not being ready is always a fear
okay this is the big nine
we put a plan together
and now they have to seriously execute
it kobe beef medium rare
i'm stuck i would like to know where all
the menus are if people drop the ball
tonight
you won't see them here tomorrow
[Music]
tonight is the night of the big relaunch
gordon ramsay's plan for a steakhouse to
fill the void in this town has generated
some buzz is that the mayor and the
restaurant is fully booked now it's up
to dean and his staff to start building
a new reputation for the old stone mill
everybody is on their tippy toes the
mayor now where does the big shot go
tonight will certainly be an indication
of
the probability of success for this
place
hello hi mr mayor it's a long time no
see i was a little intimidated when he
first walked in because he's important
to me to be here take your coat oh yes
when this place is full and the mayor's
here if you're not ready uh
i don't care how good you are come on
it's not gonna work
[Music]
with the customers and special guests
taking their seats the servers are busy
making their rounds with a new menu
[Music]
and it's obvious the pressure of the
relaunch is already getting to tom new
york strip
i'm sorry the new york strip the ribeye
and our kobe beef special
okay
it was crazy i mean this whole situation
is crazy and the whole night
obviously from the beginning was going
to be crazy
[Music]
get some napkins
done
i'm [ __ ] done
calm
i'm not comfortable with
the changes so quick but i don't know if
we're ready for it too much for me right
now i just need we need you sorry i'll
be fine i'm really well we [ __ ] need
you while tom tries to pull himself
together or you draw your eyes i i come
back as the [ __ ] manager tom okay
okay
the first wave of orders hits the
kitchen okay michael watch your
temperature yeah i don't want the steaks
coming back
okay yeah sure good
eight
party of eight who's eight whatever a8
comes in there was plenty of pressure a
couple of times i lost my composure
let's go
[Music]
and when tom does return he begins to
feel the heat once again
[Music]
i'm concerned about tom he's sweating
like a pig
i don't know what to say
i'll drive you guys too much don't you
worry
you're running around like a [ __ ]
blue ass fight yeah you're [ __ ]
sweating like a pig get in the bathroom
and do something about it when tom came
back could see he was just totally
disorganized like deranged he you know
he was nervous he was nervous
thanks
it's 45 minutes into dinner service and
though all appears to be going well
only a few customers have been served
and the mayor is not one of them
they've got a meltdown down there and
the uh mayor yeah we can't keep him
weight yeah yeah does michael know that
there's a mess table what terminal
number is that that's 12. yeah just make
sure he knows
i need the mayor's table man i'm not
getting tickets to this printer right
now why i don't know this printer right
here is not working i am not getting
tickets through this computer it's going
to [ __ ] me up no the printer's working
[Music]
oh boy it was a disaster i've already
spoken to dean about that and i finally
screamed cursed and yells get someone in
here to fix this now or we're [ __ ] i
can't believe that no one's coming in
here to fix this [ __ ] computer but if
nobody wants to hear it nobody wants to
hear it how about those stakes
how about those stakes he's [ __ ]
standing with his finger up his ass i
don't know if dean understands it'll
sink the whole night
and you'll be done oh god
now we're seriously in the ship all the
orders are backed up tables are waiting
tom switched off but more importantly
we've kept the mayor waiting 45 minutes
of all the people to keep waiting not
the [ __ ] mayor
christ
now more than an hour and 15 minutes
into service and hungry customers are
getting restless
okay michael what i need he's the
[ __ ] man now someone has to fix this
computer because i'm not getting tickets
unbelievable
get me [ __ ] dean yeah please straight
away yes
dean we have to go in the kitchen
i need the mayor's table i don't know
it's a [ __ ] hour
it's not easy getting kicked in the nuts
every day and being told that you suck
i'm [ __ ] embarrassed man where i told
you this
i don't have tickets for this why aren't
i getting tickets for this please help
me i don't remind medium rare ticket is
what i'm saying [ __ ] if this is the
copy you gotta have the other hand this
is not my ticket this comes from the
salad critter it's been an hour and i
got nothing
read the [ __ ] ticket
oh [ __ ] out there we go what the [ __ ]
you need to kick it
it's the last [ __ ] table
[Music]
i need the mayor's table man this is not
my ticket this comes from the salad
fritter it's been an hour and i got
nothing you need a [ __ ] ticket oh
[ __ ] alley we got what the [ __ ]
you need to kick it
it's the last [ __ ] table
private house for the love of [ __ ]
christ
genie two seconds yeah don't worry about
the [ __ ] coffee
mike
mike just come around for two seconds
please yes with dinner service on the
brink of disaster gordon lays it on the
line for dean and his staff let's
regroup a little bit yeah let me just
tell you the situation service has gone
we're all over the place let's get this
thing back online we've got to make
decisions especially this critical
moment this is where i need you now to
fight back this is gonna make or break
this place
i was really really pissed off but right
now for the sake of the success here i
have to just get through it let's get
some appetizers i'll pump those out real
fast and then we'll get you in there for
your entrance you know what i will be
right back and i will wrap those up for
you you know at this point now let's
work together let's correct it let's try
to correct it sorry for delay get
mistaken please
the printer's working
[Music]
good deal
yeah
good deal two medium rare
too medium
give me that it's 34.
well bon appetit i certainly hope it was
worth the wait
excellent
and thankfully dean gets everyone
focused
thank you
and the night at least finishes
successfully
[Music]
the next day gordon wants to make sure
that dean's fear of failure would no
longer stand in the way of his potential
success what really pisses you off the
most what is it i know this place is
could be a raving success
and i'm not being blind and i'm not in
the [ __ ] dream world
the fascinating thing about you dean is
that you're
you're scared of failure
walk a mile in my shoes and then we'll
talk
i failed before in business
when when i opened a restaurant in my
hometown thinking i was the dog's
bollocks and it made me the person i am
today
having both success and failure
don't be scared you can't keep on
sidestepping problems
i really believe that he's doing it for
my career now i really believe him
perhaps deep down i knew that
i needed to change and i can't overlook
things anymore
[Music]
you can't tiptoe over it this is your
business
[Music]
you're right i gotta implement changes
to make this work this time i can't wait
any longer
[Music]
with a fresh new open-minded attitude
dean masterfully took control of the
front of the house
[Music]
and the back of the house that prime rib
looks to die for right there this is the
steak for real steak eaters tom started
to gain the confidence he needs in his
role as manager did they get you drinks
yet yeah yes
and michael has rekindled his passion
for cooking showtime ladies
and to honor the old stone mill's 200th
birthday
gordon organized a celebration party for
the community and for you we'd like you
to hang this also
the city of yonkers
getting the key to the city
blew me away
i'm excited for my husband because i see
the smile back in his face
[Applause]
the local news even took notice putting
the restaurant back in the spotlight
and the new steakhouse menu was just
what this community needed and wanted
it's fantastic
finally the food is now as stunning as
the building that it's cooked in
the most important thing is the
confirmation
that it can work the potential is
staggering now that you know what to do
don't stop doing it
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you my darling yes pleasure thank
you in my heart we're gonna make it
we have to make it
up high
down below you're too slow
gordon ramsay he's such a blessing to
our family that we could never
ever thank him enough for all that he's
done for us i arrived
i found the place finally i thought it
was beautiful
now i think you got something [ __ ]
phenomenal
now i have something to really be proud
of
thanks
thank you
good luck thanks man i'm excited
i'm excited about what the future holds
here
do me a favor snip outside and have a
quick look at the front of the
restaurant
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
how do they do it where is it shooting
from wow i've wanted to sign up there
for forever i'm just overwhelmed tonight
that is so cool
you